david alors comment se déroule la
mobilisation du jour
écoutez inventa nous sommes maintenant
porte de bagnolet la mobilisation se
déroule très bien un important
dispositif de sécurité a été mise en
place encore une fois par le préféré
l'allemand beaucoup de moyens humains
qui encadrent le cortège
aucun débordement à signaler la
manifestation se passe dans le calme et
de manière pacifique je me trouve
actuellement avec rémy rémy qui est
gilet jaune depuis le premier acte rémy
est ce que vous attendiez ce que le
mouvement des gilet jaune dure autant
dans le temps oui oui personnellement
oui c'est à dire qu'on a été surpris on
va dire pour sur 4 samedi les quatre
premiers samedi mais après n'ayant pas
de réponse de nos gouvernants on
s'attendait
à ce que ça dure dans le temps à ce que
ça soit une bataille et médiatique et de
mobilisation donc on est là on nous
sommes les français et on sera là encore
115 samedi à faire 812 jours à faire on
sera là et de voir qu'il ya autant
l'interdiction de manifester qu'est ce
que ça vous évoque avoue une répression
c'est les non réponses du gouvernement
c'est on attend des réponses sociales et
économiques
à la place on a de l'arrêt de la
répression donc c'est pas satisfaisant
pour nous les français c'est pour ça que
a émergé la demande du rich dans la
constitution pour voir destituer les
gouvernants qui font pas le travail et
pour pouvoir aussi faire du référendum
sur par exemple les retraites qui est
fondamental pour les français c'est pas
normal que les français n'est pas le mot
sur ce dossier là c'est inacceptable
le référendum pour les retraites en est
question sont toujours les mêmes depuis
un an
voilà
comment augmentation en baisse pardon
baisse du carburant 1 euro 1 euro les
carburants ce serait humains pour
pouvoir vie pour que le tiers pauvres
puissent vivre augmentation de 300 euros
net par mois pour le plus public privé
aussi les allocations handicapés voilà
et le rich oui ça n'a pas changé
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
la question rémy là vous l'aurez compris
les revendications sont toujours les
mêmes pour les jaunes pour cet acte 66
66e samedi de protestation la
mobilisation se poursuit avec aussi
cette revendication la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale et la création
d'états généraux citoyens afin de
réécrire une constitution voilà
l'objectif principal de gilet jaune
la mobilisation se poursuit et le
cortège va bientôt atteindre son point
final qui est qui et les buttes chaumont